A key construct at most exchanges
is something called the order book.
Each exchange keeps an order book for
every stock that they buy or sell.
And here's how it works.
Let's suppose you've just issued
an order to buy 100 shares of IBM
with a limit price of 99.95.
And let's suppose for
the moment that this arrives at
the New York Stock Exchange and so
far today nobody's put in any orders.
So your order is the first one and
they'll use it as the basis to
start building their order book.
So yours is the first
entry in the order book.
And it simply shows somebody has
bid 99.95 for 100 shares of stock.
And this is public knowledge.
People can view this and see, okay,
there's interest in buying
shares of this stock.
Now, they don't know
who has made this bid.
The exchange knows that it's
you that's made that bid.
But they see that there's
interest in 100 shares.
Now others may send
in orders like yours.
And this number just keeps
getting larger depending on
how many orders come in.
When this is displayed publicly,
people just see that okay,
there's interest maybe
from various people.
And 1,000 shares of IBM at 99.95.
So far nothing's been bought or sold yet
though because we don't have
anybody willing to sell.
Well, let's suppose
a sell order comes in.
Sell IBM 1,000 shares, limit of $100.
Well, there's nobody willing
to buy 1000 shares at $100.
So, the exchange again, is going to have
to add this order to it's order book.
And this will be our first ask.
We've got now our first ask
as part of our order book.
Now let's say more and
more orders come in.
And it fleshes out our order book a bit.
Here's our order book as it's fleshed
out a bit, as orders have come in.
We've got a number of asks,
which are requests to sell stocks, and
a number of bids,
which are requests to buy.
Suppose now we get a market order
to buy 100 shares of stock.
Here's our new order,
and here's what happens.
The Exchange looks at
it's order book and
it sees, yes,
we have lots of shares for sale here.
We have to give the client the lowest
price so we'll give that client
100 shares of these that
are priced at $100.
So, that means now we've
only got 900 left here,
we take that 100, give that to
the client who put in the order and
this is the state now of our order
book after that transaction.